(audience clapping)
Now, today
is one of my favorite days, it's Pop Quiz!
(bell ringing)
(audience cheering)
(dramatic music)
I love these.
Okay, during our final segment, we're gonna ask
one audience member three questions about today's show.
Uh-huh, so if you answer all three correctly,
you win $1,000.
(cha-chinging)
(audience cheering)
And it's $100 for any that you do get right,
so I think win-win and we'll play along,
see you at the end of the show, pay attention, here we go.
(audience clapping)
It's time for our
Pop Quiz!
Yeah!
(bell ringing)
(audience cheering)
All right, Nicole Hinkle, you've been selected!
Come on!
(Drew laughing)
Well hello!
Oh my gosh!
Hi!
Oh, that was so fun you didn't know!
(Nicole breath hitching)
I love that.
Oh my God!
(audience laughing)
Hi, Nicole,
how are you?
Hi!
Oh my God, sorry, I love you.
(Ross laughing)
I love you too!
(audience clapping)
Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Now, were you paying attention to the show all day?
Yes, very much so.
Did you blink even once?
Maybe just once.
(Nicole laughing)
Okay good.
Well we're gonna quiz you on what happened today, okay?
Okay.
(taking deep breath) Okay,
Nicole, if you correctly answer three questions
about today's show, you'll win $1,000!
Are you ready?
Oh my God.
(audience clapping)
She want $1,000.
And 100 for every question answered right,
so even if you get one, you get something.
All right, first question;
how old was Donny Osmond when he made his TV debut?
At just five years old,
Donny made his TV debut on "The Andy Williams Show'.
Five.
(bell dinging)
Oh, that's right.
(audience clapping and cheering)
$100, okay.
Question number two; in the polenta that Drew made
with Danny Seo, did she use fresh or frozen broccoli?
Oh and they're frozen!
They're frozen on purpose,
so this is something where you don't need fresh broccoli.
Frozen broccoli is actually just as fresh,
all the nutrients are locked in,
and what it does, it helps it keep its shape.
(audience laughing)
Beautiful.
Frozen.
(bell dinging)
(audience clapping)
That's $200.
Okay, this is it!
Oh my God, I get so excited.
For $1,000.
Okay, final question; according to "The Atlantic",
what does one couple schedule with one another?
There's one married couple from New Jersey
who's been doing it for 40 years now.
But how? By scheduling their fights.
"The Atlantic" reports Liz Cutler and Tom Creutz
swear by this system, they schedule a disagreement meeting
once every three months.
Fights.
(bell dinging)
That's it.
(audience cheering)
You got it.
(upbeat music)
(ca-chinging)
(sing-songy) $1,000!
Now, this is for you, $1,000, but wait.
Wait, you have the $1,000 there in your hand,
but we have a twist, Drew.
Well, you can walk away with your $1,000 today,
or you can give it back to us right now
and you can come back tomorrow to play a super-sized
Pop Quiz for the chance to win...
$5,000!
(audience cheering)
I will come back tomorrow.
She's giving it back! Give it back!
(Drew cheering)
(audience clapping)
Drew! I love it!
I'm on my knees,
what's wrong with me?! Oh my God!
(audience clapping and laughing)
This is just so exciting,
we're finally seeing the potential of Pop Quiz.
(laughing) God, I love how excited you are.
I am so excited it's like, you know?
Reaching the top of Everest, you're just like,
"We're gonna get there one day." And here we are.
Pull it together, Barrymore, all right.
Neva!
You took a risk, you gave back the $1,000,
so tomorrow we're gonna see you for the chance to win 5K.
Yay!
(audience cheering)
(bright music)